Now, Box2D was originally written in C++, horded the action script, and used in
hundreds of games. Including the incredibly popular Angry Birds. And recently
the action script version of Box2D has also been converted further to
JavaScript by Jonas Wagner. For grits, we grab the JavaScript part of Box2D
from the Intertubes and placed it into our source folder. Now, if you have
further questions about the Box2D API that we don't answer here. We recommend
you take a look at the Box2D manual shown here, and linked below. It was
written for the Flash version, but the concepts translate. Now, the first thing
we need to do to use Box2DJS is to load it into the Dom. And we do that, using
this fairly simple script tag.